let's bring out someone very special to
us shall we uh who would that be
it's your assistant David hopping oh my
other assistant because Sona is usually
busy oh and so I have David hopping
David
a quick question did you get to meet
Kelly Clarkson I did you did I did okay
we were this is this is we were driving
today together and we're uh listening to
Kelly's new album chemistry and um at
one point we've finished like the third
or fourth song and I said oh that song's
uh that's really good and you looked at
me and said it's impossible for Kelly to
have a bad song it's true it's true I
know but you are such a fanatic it must
have been nice to meet her that is I
brought a vinyl she signed up for me oh
I didn't ask you if I could do that
because I didn't want to risk you saying
no so I just brought it well now I look
like a controlling to everybody
I thought the answer is I would like it
and I will shred it in front of it
um no I would have said yes I you really
so you really were afraid to ask me if
you could I actually wasn't no you just
forgot yeah I just forgot okay it's
easier to say I'm afraid than I forgot
I'm glad I'm glad you met her isn't she
nice she is really nice thank you yeah
oh please you let it you've made it
happen he told me yesterday he was like
you're gonna get one-on-one time and
then I wasn't sure if it was a bit or if
it was true and it was true what what do
you and Sona always think that my acts
of kindness are a cruel joke
yeah
he said something nice earlier and I
started getting super defensive yeah
yeah
sound time one-on-one time with uh Kelly
Clarkson and I half meant it
I knew that I would be able to swing it
yeah she's so nice that's gonna say no
I'm out of here I've performed what I
needed to do now I'm gone she's just a
lovely person where is she now I think
she's working the hallway because they
gave her such a great reception when she
walked out so how can we help you David
uh I think you're gonna take some
questions from I have no idea what's
happening I don't know why that's I
honestly thought you were bringing me my
lunch
anyone has a question raise your hand
yeah
so when's your new HBO Max show stuff oh
thank you for asking uh we
I I shot this show as you know we do
this podcast and then I we talked to
Famous folk like Kelly Clarkson but then
uh usually in the middle of the week I
talked to anyone in the world who just
wants to talk to me and so the idea was
many of these conversations as you guys
know because you're there and with them
saying well Conan if you're ever in
Nigeria hop on stop on by and they say
it kind of like a joke so what we
decided to do is a show that HBO Max
said they wanted to do uh where I talked
to them you see a minute or two clip of
that and then I show up at their door
and I get involved in their life and the
Conan remote style where I'm I'm
literally going through their kitchen
and tearing open their closets and then
trying to help them achieve what it is
they wanted to achieve or work out a
problem they have with their mom which
is an episode that we shot in Bangkok
and
um so I we shot some of them and then
the writer strike came
and so we shut everything down and so
and so the writer's Guild is satisfied
and they get a good because I started
out as a as a TV writer and so I'm
backing them a thousand percent until
they get what they want we the show will
uh
the show will sort of stay in limbo and
then whenever that gets resolved we can
uh I I hope uh finish it up so all of us
right now in this business are just
waiting to see uh what's gonna happen
but there is a there was a trailer
that's out there that people can check
out if you want it's called Conan
O'Brien must go yeah and
uh people do like a title that shits on
me